who had the most expensive funeral ever
that would be Alexander the Great in 323
BC who definitely went out with a bang
he was packed into a solid-gold casket
and sarcophagus then transported from
Babylon to Macedonia in a solid-gold
carriage drawn by sixty horses the
carriage was so heavy a special road had
to be constructed for the procession and
legend has it his body restored in honey
to delay decomposition this little
going-away party cost six hundred
million dollars in today's currency gold
coffins aside the US Labor Department
reports that costs related to death have
risen much faster than almost anything
else in the last thirty years from 1986
to 2017 the consumer price index grew by
95 percent while caskets rose by 230
percent over the same period
forget the rising cost of living dying
is the real wallet buster there are a
few topics people avoid discussing more
than money and death so mixing these
taboo topics has resulted in any Norma's
lack of understanding when it comes to
the financial side of dying so consider
us your grim tour guides on a financial
exhumation of what you can expect your
loved ones to pay once you breathed your
last
[Music]
the industries related to death and
dying have learned to exploit an obvious
weakness in the shopping process
dreaming families are not in a state of
mind to be financially savvy the
emotional drain to comparison shop look
over pricing lists and develop a
detailed burial plan is not something
most relatives want to deal with and
since most people don't like thinking
about their own mortality over half of
people don't have a will seeing as how
the death rate seems to be holding
steady around a hundred percent odds are
you will eventually have to make some
funeral related decisions for a loved
one or yourself how much could it end up
costing if you or a loved one is pushing
up daisies without putting together a
plan I think it's time to Martha
recently gave up her oxygen habit and
since she left no will behind her
daughter Breanna has to navigate the
financial decisions involved with her
passing Martha died in hospital which
according to a recent study is over six
times more expensive than dying at home
with an average final mill of 32
thousand three hundred seventy nine
dollars yep now Breanna has to make
decisions regarding a funeral service
the average basic funeral home service
fee is twenty-one hundred dollars which
takes care of the death certificate
permits and sheltering the remains
she'll have to transport the body her
family is requesting a viewing and the
funeral director recommended embalming
Plus makeup and hair services she'll
need some staff to help manage the
ceremony a Memorial printed package
flowers wreaths a basic metal casket
funeral plot and last but not least a
headstone and even with the funeral
taking care of Breanna is still not done
yet because she's the executor of
Martha's estate since she's busy and the
time involved in sorting out Martha's
affairs without a will is overwhelming
hires an estate attorney it's not
uncommon for a state attorneys fees to
reach as high as $2,000 according to one
industry leader so that's just one more
nail in the coffin the Grim Reaper's
final invoice a heart-stopping fifty
four thousand thirty nine dollars no
wonder there are so many GoFundMe
campaigns for final expenses
remember these are simply averages but
since Bartha didn't have a will
specifying her wishes it's not
surprising Breanna went along with these
normal-seeming choices most people would
feel weird about trying to save a buck
in this situation Martha's estate will
be required to pay these fees but
there's not enough the rest will fall
upon her family it's kind of a bummer
that arrangements for your death is one
of the most expensive things you'll ever
buy and you won't even be around to
enjoy it so is there anything you can do
while you're still alive to reduce the
financial impact of dying
first and foremost having a will could
have saved a lot of expense and headache
for everyone it's possible that Martha
didn't want to spend her last days in a
hospital and would have opted for care
in a nursing facility hospice or even at
home all of which cost significantly
less the price of drafting a simple will
is often around $1,000 with an attorney
or just a few hundred dollars with the
turnkey service like Legal Zoom are
willing calm considering it might help
your loved ones avoid thousands of
dollars in legal fees after you're gone
that's a dead simple financial decision
and in your will you can specify what
you do and don't want in the way of
services and arrangements you can even
plan ahead by setting aside funds for
your final resting place in the form of
a small life insurance policy or even
funeral insurance which helps you hedge
against rising prices there are other
options besides a pricy casket and
burial for your remains a cremation is
significantly cheaper often just four
hundred to a thousand dollars and even
less expensive than cream
is a private burial that's right in many
areas especially very loved with
yourself on your own property you could
also donate your body to science and the
institution or university will usually
pick up the cost including information
after they're done it remains or you
might have seen a handsome Facebook
promoting biodegradable burial pods a
concept that promises to grow your
remains into a beautiful tree there's
even a nonprofit called eternal reefs
that makes your remains with concrete
and put them underwater in an effort to
restore coral reefs whatever your
decision about your final resting place
it should be exactly that your decision
don't put off putting a plan into place
you don't want your final legacy to be
sticking your friends and family with a
large bill and ghosting and that's our
two cents thanks to our patrons for
keeping two cents financially healthy
click the link in the description if you
would like to support us on patreon if
you've ever had to deal with funeral
costs what expense took you most by
surprise we'd love to hear about it in
the comments
you
[Music]